so my name is ruined
I'm a data scientist a channel
and we're talking through some research
ideas kind of in conjunction with UCL
last year on forecasting television
ratings we'll probably start off with a
bit of a quick introduction to like the
TV market and the art market and why
forecasting is important we'll move on
to some characteristics of the data will
plots and like temporal effects and
program effects of the data to get a
kind of a feel for and then we'll move a
bit more into the modeling how do we tie
those things together we'll look at how
we deal with changing distributions in
the data so when the distribution of
programs ratings are changing how do we
deal with that starting off with simple
forgetting or kind of just basically
down weighting older data and then we'll
show that the extension of standard
forgetting to the Bayesian case is
actually really really simple and
actually kind of it over some doors to
kind of like new and interesting methods
of estimating what's the best kind of
forgetting factor we should be using
because until recently there hasn't been
very much guidance about like how do we
decide how much to forget old data and
it kind of I suppose the takeaway is
either forgetting is like very quite
effective and quite simple and B that I
think it's quite nice because we'll show
that by kind of turning the screw of
like probability theory and information
theory we come out with like really
intuitive and kind of pleasing results
for ways of estimating the forgetting
factor so I'll start off with the
introduction check out of the ad market
so firstly I guess what is it we're
projecting we're predicting a TVR so one
TVR represents one percent of a
population watching a program
so if 10 percent of all people are
watching TV ten percent of them are
watching channel 4 channel 4 get the TVR
of 1% so it's quite straightforward it's
kind of on there like 0 to 100 or zero
to one kind of interval really important
thing is how we measure this so like the
art market and TV can't really exist
without measuring this quantity really
well so actually the advertisers and
broadcasters for quite a lot of money
into doing this in a kind of transparent
way that they're both happy with and
this is that
called barb the British audience
resource Research Board so they've
convicted of about 51 homes that are
chose to be representative throughout
the UK
and they do hope they've got like
hardware in their homes and they do
loads of monitoring
so apart from monitoring how many people
are watching kind of the most important
thing that really gets measured is who
is watching so definitely particularly
from their advertisers point of view
they're really interested in not just
how many people but specifically the who
typically an advertiser or a brand
they're really only interested in kind
of like zeroing in on and targeting like
one specific subset of the population
and I mean like BMW probably know that
no matter how many ads I see of theirs I
can't afford to buy BMW so they're kind
of really keen to just like really zero
in on people who they think are actually
gonna buy their products and and this is
kind of so forecasting the who as well
it's kind of the key to demographic
targeting in television so they have
there's 16 actual fixed audiences you
can buy so you can buy like ABC ones or
off Marcus so that's actually defined
it's just if you work at a desk
there's also housewives which me male or
female but it's defined as the person in
the house who typically does the
groceries so you can see it's a little
bit dated you can see how all the TV
industry is so you but the important
thing is that a brand just picked up one
of these and then they only pay for
impressions from that audience so I
guess the good example be a BMW come to
us and they say we want five ABC one TV
ours will say that's fine we can deliver
a lot and then for whatever reason we
decide what there are in an episode of
like The Inbetweeners a really young
show and a million young people watch
that but only 200,000 ABC ones watch it
we only get paid for the two hundred
thousand ABC ones and we didn't get paid
for the million young that watched her
so we should have bought a young ad in
our place and you're talking about
pretty significant amount of money for
like a thirty second bit of advertising
I think cost of one young TVR you're
probably talking about like nearly ten
thousand pounds so yeah you've kind of
you stand to lose quite a lot of money
some of the time
it's like kind of to put it into context
like why we're interested in this
yeah so we'll do bit of visualization of
the data - so here's a subset of like
broadcasts on the x-axis we've got the
young rating so percent of 16 to 34 that
watch the program on the X we are on the
Y we've got ABC one so kind of up
markets that watch the program you can
see it's quite like multimodal the lined
and the middle kind of shows like where
it's about the same whereas about as
many ABC ones are watching as Young's
you notice in the top left we've got a
cluster words like really skewing like
upmarket
in a big way I like you need to know is
that that cluster there is about 10
times more valuable if we place an ABC
one out rather than a young out so we
place a young add in any of those top
left broadcasts we're probably losing
tens of thousands of parents possibly
from hundreds of has advanced so that's
kind of - I suppose if visualize what
I've been trying to at the point we're
trying to make now we're gonna kind of
layer on the program information and
that's going to show us something nice
it's gonna show us that like knowing
what the program is it's very predictive
of like what are the ratings are gonna
be so if we layered on this one in the
top left that we were locking up shark
young people don't like canals that much
so I mean I guess anyone could've
probably told you that but it's kind of
nice from a forecasting boy view it
means like we know great canal journeys
is always gonna skew old so I think old
old and rich I mean but so I guess the
takeaway from these kind of two graphs
is that past
program performance is a really strong
predictor and it's something that really
needs to be incorporated any model we
look up so the next thing we look is
some kind of temporal temporal
characteristics to the data so we look
at like this is a week's just like a
random week of data colored by J you can
clearly see where the weekend is the
last two days it's like much more data
on viewing not as much in the nighttime
and then kind of you can see the daily
things peaking about eight or nine so
you can see there's strong like like
time of day effects the interesting
thing is gogglebox was on
that peak at this time and I was just
doing insanely well so I'm the shocking
thing about this graph is that eighty
percent of ABC ones would rather watch
people watch TV then go out and do
something on a Friday night so so that's
kind of a bit of an outlier that Friday
night racing we look through then the
seasonal like during the year as you'd
expect basically it starts off high in
the winter I kind of slowly declines as
the weather gets better that's not
surprising at all the interesting is you
can really distinctly see August when
the schools go on break and everyone
just like jump ship from England which
is just right this big trough there so I
suppose looking at those two things the
main thing is we need a way that like
ties together kind of time based
predictors and other things like genre
and repeat status along with the pass
ratings of like the programming question
is basically we also want to be able to
so it's important that if we have a show
that we've never seen before we can
still make a good prediction in there
like cold star kiss so that's quite
important as well so one of the main
models that's proposed in the literature
is a random effects model this is quite
a good model if you've got like repeated
measurements from different groups it
sort of decouples like the time effects
and the genre effects from like the
program specific effects so you've got
they're kind of fixed effects which
would be like genre Tom J which is X and
then the Delta P is programmed specific
so you're kind of saying that we expect
all programs to react the same way to a
change in time of day or like day of
year or genre or whatever so we expect
just like homeland to respond the same
way to be moving from an IBM software
flaw kittens fall respect that respect
the same way like across programs well
each program has its own sort of
inherent like natural appeal that's not
captured by those core areas and lastly
small saying we'll look at we'll just do
a quick comparison to a ordinary
least-squares because when I first
looked at random effects model wasn't
clear who's like exactly how it was
different so we've got
some group said we've got three groups
program a B and C color here free fit
and OLS just onto the explanatory
variable X as it expected just like
quiet good job like minimizing the
squared error like to the line but it's
disregarding all that group information
so now I've used stock models here so
starts models also as a good at mixed
effects implementation for doing the
random effects optimization so it's just
a change in objective but it results in
a completely different kind of sloped
line so this is just based on the fixed
effects and you can see what happens in
the random effects model is that
actually finds the slope that's common
to all groups and fits like the within
group slope the best so you can see
actually each groups slope is about -1
the global slope is about +1 but within
each group its y -1 so it's finding that
like slope that's common to all groups
and then when you include the round of
effect you got like quite good
predictions so really basically all so
the beta re that kind of captures like
the mean structure of the data and then
you've got the Delta parameters which
then give you your like inherent appeal
above or below that average and you end
up with these colored lines showing like
each within group prediction so we'll
look at some real data now we're going
to look at homeland so we're just this
model was trained on like all of the
data but we're just gonna focus on their
whole lot predictions so we're gonna
layer it on a bit so this kind of blue
shaded region is the training period so
up here we've got the ratings for
homeland in the training period it's
doing quite well it's like 10 percent
share quite good will air on just the
fixed effects prediction now so the
prediction just based on like time of
day edge on and repeat service and that
kind of represents like the average so
that's kind of like what we would expect
any drama on channel 4 to be doing at 9
o'clock on a Thursday or whatever it was
so it's kind of doing actually a bit
better than we'd expect from a typical
drama at that time we'll layer on the
random effects projections so these are
gonna be the the main prediction that
we're interested in so we'll see a few
of these graphs now going forward and
always if these red crosses are really
what we're interested in these the final
prediction that we
you can see the random effect is kind of
capturing like the average deviation
from the fixed effect line so the final
predictions in the training period are
like quite well capturing sort of the
mean structure of the ratings and you
know I'm relatively happy with this you
know we're not on the prediction or over
predicting we're probably have nice
normally distributed residuals so this
is kind of what we want but then we move
into the tester so these are now the
kind of test period ratings and you can
see there's been like not drastic but
noticeable decline in the popularity of
the show we're down to come about nine
percent sure so on average is probably
dropped by about a percentage point
which does mean that when we predict in
the test period we're kind of we're
persisting with the level of popularity
that we witnessed in the training period
and without like a mechanism to kind of
deal this and adapt to changes in show
popularity we just stick with that I'm
like naively and of systematically over
predicting one nice thing I suppose that
comes out of this as you can see the
last broadcast is super low but the
model has like to some extent predicted
that it's going to be really low and
this is because this final one I think
was a repeat of the final episode so
that's completely as it expect but it
shows at least that kind of the
combination of fixed effects and random
facts is kind of it has that nice
characteristic where you can track show
performance but relative to like whether
it's a review or not so I guess the next
thing is we really really need to like
address the fact that we just need to
live with the fact that the distribution
of show ratings changes as time goes on
so a standard way of dealing with like
drift or kind of non iid data is to down
wait old data so this is a simple idea
like your latest data point gets away of
one and all the old data gets away lower
than one typically like getting lower as
you go back really is it calculate and
in fact if you just decide you're going
to have a fixed way you can do this
recursively and just keep down waiting
you accumulate like the storm and
account of the
you just keep Dan waiting the last time
steps statistics at each time and this
is actually called the recursively
squares algorithm it's really fast it's
really simple and it's actually quite
good at like tracking changes in
parameters so you see with homeland when
you do online RLS with like forgetting
factor about 0.9 to 5 you can see it's
still not perfect but it's a lot better
than before you can see it's still the
first couple of app stores in the second
season we're still over predicting but
quite quickly we come down and we're
actually quite close to then the mean
here and then by the time we're here
we're basically right back where we want
to be so I mean that's kind of quick and
easy it's nice I'm relatively effective
it will be nice to have like maybe some
like predictive uncertainty I may be
uncertain in some of our parameter
estimates so we'll move on and look at
how you can do this in a Bayesian way I
don't to give like a tutorial on like
Bayesian inference so I'm just going to
really show the solution like if you're
interested in like conjugate inference
of a normal it's all either but
essentially the solution is this all you
need to do to have a posterior is track
the sum of the data the number of the
data on the sum of the squared data and
you accumulate these in like a matrix
we're gonna call V and you just keep the
count and thing called new and then this
is your posterior it's actually a nice
standard for normal inverse gamma even
if it looks a bit scary but it's not
super important but the point is I guess
you only need to track a small number of
sufficient statistics to harbor
posterior distribution oh it's the full
posterior and it's tractable or nice
quite nice to work with unimportant you
can update those statistics recursively
and almost exactly the same way as with
your or less algorithm and you can see
so V 0 nu 0 or like your prior but if
you've got an on and board of fire
they're probably going to be like the 0
matrix or close to 0 and it just means
that again in the same way as are less
your latest observations are gonna
dominate your latest estimation of the
mean depending on how I forget o'clock
to W star
so I think this is the main thing to
take home is that it's quite easy
I've even thrown in the code for doing
this like literally these are just the
two lines for the recursive object you
just extend the current observation by
one and take the outer project that was
itself and you accumulate those and you
use the forgetting factor these are the
two marginals on the mean and the
variance any of you've maybe got
experience this might notice that I've
simulated 2000 data points but still the
posterior looks quite flash this is
because I thought the forgetting factor
of 0.9 5 so this means is actually if
you've got to forget in fact 4.95
the effective number of data that you're
using is 1 over 1 minus the regatta
factor so in this case we're actually
only ever using about 20 effective data
points and that's why this posterior
it's constantly limited it's the
forgetting performs this like constant
flattening of the posterior so we're
never getting to certain which is coming
through because we've imposed to this
idea that we expect the distribution
might change so we never want to
accumulate lots of certainty so that's
kind of just a natural outcome of
Bayesian for hearing so that shows it's
pretty easy to implement in the simple
case and then we can have nice kind of
predictive distributions or got slightly
blue shaded areas showing plus or minus
one standard deviation of the predictive
distribution and it looks about right
you know there's not really any real
data laughing too far outside but but
the actual point predictions are about
the same the predictive decision looks
like this is Atiya distribution so this
is kind of important because we're going
to come back to this later and this
distribution becomes key when we
actually get to estimating a good
forgetting factor from the data the
important thing I guess is the T
distribution as you gain more data so
it's got a property called degrees of
freedom but basically the more data you
have the closer it comes to a normal but
the left area have the heavier the table
seem to see the blue case we've only got
one data point some really really heavy
tails you've got a density going really
really wide and that makes sense because
if you've only seen one data point why
would you be certain about anything
so back characteristic of the
distribution is really important
so we'll move on to actually trying to
look at maybe yesterday forgetting
laughter so just to see the importance
of it
comparing what we have 0.9 to five to
fifty two point five I mean in the case
where it's point five there's huge
variance in our predictions and we're
kind of we're really fitting to a lot of
noise we're almost just predicting
whatever the last data point was which
may be sometimes it's not bad maybe in
that case you want an AR 1 model but
typically we're TV railing ratings they
actually are quite stable you kind of
want to suppress that noise and you
don't want to be letting like one
outlier take your estimates right down
so it does it is usually it's usually
suggested to like have a pretty high
forgetting factor unless you have
incredibly like fast fast changing
parameters so other reasons we want to
estimate the forgetting factor is that
like a guy did a bit of cross validation
initially to set one for recursive these
squares
I'm not did inform later when we had to
choose the prior but also different
chosing have different like rates of
change of their ratings like the
Simpsons on a static clock is just never
gonna change it's gonna be the same
pretty much forever
well stuff like home labs dramas divert
last episodes they're much more likely
to change so it'll be nice if we could
have like a different forgetting factor
for each program also if you've got a
fixed forgetting factor you can't
actually track fast changes so if you're
programming factor is fixed to 0.95 and
then you've got sudden drop in ratings
it's going to take you about 10
observations to like acclimatize that
new level of popularity because you're
still using effectively about 20 data
points so if you've got a variable for
your bacteria that looks at the road and
says maybe I should drop then you can
adapt to these sudden changes quite
quickly and we'll see that so I'm going
to digress now and just look I kind of
I've just got a couple of like quite
nasty slides because I think it's really
interesting how you go from sort of just
probably an information to like a
practical intractable solution so we
have to look at the interpretation of
forgetting in the kind of the basing
context so this is like the standard
Bayesian filtering update and that's
kind of the
reduces the Kalman filter if like you
know this parameter evolution model so
this orange thing here is really
important because it's the thing that we
don't have when we're forecasting TV
ratings that makes this difficult if we
had that we could probably resort to a
common filter and have like the optimal
Bayesian filtering solution which would
be nice
well the fact is we just don't have a
model for like how the ratings are going
to change from time now to the next
really but the regarding factor actually
defines a bound on how far the posterior
can change from now to the next time so
we think if you I've got a forgetting
factor of one I'm basically saying that
the posterior cannot change until I see
the next data point so you can see that
what we're trying to get is the F of U n
plus 1 given only is that 1 to N so if
you've got forgetting factor of 1 you're
saying that it has to be the same as
this so if you're forgetting about just
1 you're saying this is the same as that
definitely so you're bound on the
divergence between the two things isn't
necessarily 0 and that's kind of a
really important thing to recognize is
that because the programing factor
defines this bound on how far the
posterior can move between time steps
it's now necessarily a measure on the
parameter evolution model and we can
conclude our search here so that's kind
of an important takeaway I guess and it
turns out that the posterior here that
results from a certain W is the
distribution that has the maximum
entropy of all distributions that
satisfy this bound and the maximum max
every distribution is kind of it's
strongly argued by James and many others
that if you don't know much about the
posterior except that it belongs to a
class of distributions either satisfies
AB and then the optimal and like minimum
risk distribution is the maximum entropy
distribution of that class of
distributions so if that's kind of over
your head but maybe I haven't explained
a lot well that's sort of okay but I
guess the point is like forgetting has a
really like rich I'm kind of satisfying
justification I was like an approximate
distribution
on on a true posterior when we don't
know the parameter evolution model and
then this leads us to possible ways of
actually estimating out so given what
I've just said the joint posterior on
the latest parameter mu N and the latest
forgetting factor is that this is kind
of just a big long Bayes rule but it's
the likelihood of the latest data times
the prior evolution model which is now a
function of the forgetting factor times
the or posterior times our prior on the
forget a factor it's kind of long but
that's it's basically just Bayes rule
and you can integrate out the parameter
mu and which we can actually do because
our posterior on that is a standard form
normal inverse gamma so we actually
can't integrate that out and it turns
out so when we integrate all of the
Meuse here you get the likelihood or the
posterior on the forgetting factor is
proportional to this likelihood which is
actually just the T distribution which
we saw times a prior on the way around
the W so if we actually look so we look
at the likelihood now so remember the T
distribution that we saw and we saw that
I'd kind of flattened out when you did
less data so this is now the likelihood
for our forgetting factor and if you
imagine every as you decrease your
forgetting factor you're decreasing the
amount of data so here are three
different distributions given different
forgetting factors so the orange one is
if we settle for getting parts at 0.05
and we're basically saying we have
almost no data the predictive
distribution at that time then is really
really heavy tailed and it'll give more
density to observations in the tail so
what you're doing is you're saying my
observation of time n would have been
this likely a for time n minus one we'd
set forgetting factor to X if that makes
sense so you can see if we set it really
high if we set to 0.95 because the
latest observation is kind of actually
quite far away from where our mean
was forgetting factor of 0.95 becomes
very unlikely so this is actually this
is kind of the formal kind of Bayesian
estimation of the forgetting factor and
it's come through this like quite nice
intuitive algorithm that says you know
if the last observation was unlikely on
our predictive distribution then maybe
the organic matter should be glowed and
that's kind of what this likelihood says
because that's the observation is quite
far out so we just got a few other
examples so if we move it in its
likelihood of staying one remains closer
and then if the observation is right at
the peak then the absolute max is where
the forgetting factor is one just here
but one thing we see is that the
likelihoods are really flat and this
kind of makes sense because actually if
the latest observations come from an
area of density there's very little to
say why it would have come from any
other distribution so if if the latest
data comes from an area that's quite
dense in our current posterior it's very
hard to know whether it has come from
that or a slightly different
distribution so again this sort of if
you think about it it kind of makes
sense the likelihoods flat but it does
mean that we have to like impose quite a
strong prior and really we do actually
expect ratings to be relatively stable
for quite long periods of time you know
we don't actually expect it to kind of
go like right down or right back up we
do expect like long periods of stability
so this is the prior we've chosen it's a
mixture of better prior so you've got a
lower component which kind of has mass
everywhere but mostly a zero and then a
high component which is by far our
dominant I think we used a weighting by
0.9 to 5 for this component 0.1 for the
low component and this color just says
we strongly expects the forgetting
factor to be up around 1 think the
expected value of the prior is 0.93 so
this can I says not strongly what we
expect but we are going to allow
forgetting factors in other areas if the
evidence is like a strong you know
unfavorable and then some of the
posterior distributions resulting from
that are here
so these are relating to some of the
some of the examples we gave earlier so
if the likelihood is like this so this
likelihood is peaked right towards zero
because we've imposed that strong prior
we're actually still most of our masses
up here and we ended with an expected
value of about 0.5 6 for the programming
Podger
and then it's so really it has to be
like very unlikely under the current
posterior predictive to merit like a
drop in the forgotten factor so we'll
just look now finally I'd like some real
data so shipping wars who's doing pretty
well for its first like ten broadcasts
share about 4% then on the tenth
broadcast for some reason which we
haven't been able to model it just like
suddenly drops like a stone so then
because of this the model says that was
so unlikely under our predictive
distribution we're gonna say it's
probably a change in the distribution of
the data and a drop so the forgetting
factor which is these here so we've been
pretty stable up between like 0.8 and 1
mostly by 0.9 when we see that drop it
chops right down to zero and there are
predictions which of these red crosses
drop wither and actually continue to
sort of capture like the mean structure
of the data and you can see the variance
also comes down with a so if we compare
this diff we have like a fixed
forgetting of 0.9 to 5 it Cana you kind
of see the benefit I guess so if we have
a fixed forgetting factor of 0.9 to 5
you can see the predictions are just
like slowly trying to acclimatize to
this new level of popularity but there's
just there's always going to be a lag
depending on your forgetting factor and
you can see as well when the data
changes instead of attributing it to a
change in the mean it's been attributed
to just a really big increase in
variance so you can see before the drop
the variance and the predictive
distribution is you know it's not that
bad as soon as this drops here the
models kind of saying
suddenly our data is like really highly
variable so you end up with bad
predictions
and also bad uncertainty estimates where
is on the left hand side you can see the
predictions remain good and the variance
remains about where it was which is kind
of what we want and then just one more
example is Gordon Ramsay similar thing
this one's not as clear-cut which kind
of makes the more satisfying our guest
from the modeling point of view that's
still quite good at tracking things when
it's like not insanely obvious that
there's been a big change so this is a
little bit more of like a slow downward
trend in the ratings of Gordon Ramsay
we've got one case where it does drop
quite low in the worst rating case and
you can see again the ratings drop the
uncertainty remains about the same which
is good and again we kind of we're doing
okay in terms of predictions and pre
compares to with the fixed forgetting
factor again a similar thing happens
where we've got suddenly our variance
kind of just explodes the actual point
predictions aren't too much worse is
about 23 percent error compared to 21
with the variable forgetting factor but
if someone was to ask me like how
uncertain or in this prediction I'd be
saying we're wildly uncertain we it
could practically be anywhere which
actually isn't the case the case of our
authority is much better reflected I
feel by on the left hand side where most
of the day is lying within one standard
deviation but not beyond and that's
pretty much it from me I've got there is
a few main references that this was
based on one most one mainly on
forecasts in TV ratings by Peter Danaher
and then a few on forgetting and
recursive estimation by Carney and Corp
kavaja the top one is probably the main
one that describes estimating forget
butter which in practice was done I
showed like numerically evaluated
posterior and like the odds but in
practice we implemented just like what a
simple particle filter which did that
but it was very very simple but yeah so
how does that any questions we hop
dancer
[Applause]
hi so here you're forecasting each each
program in isolation in a way but is
there any way you can think of extending
this to modeling the interaction with
what's happening on the other channels I
mean maybe nothing happened on those
massive drops but being lid was playing
Germany on football yeah same time yes
so it's a really good point we have
actually I have try doing this this
bottom paper does actually proposed to
do that so I tried models that modeled
child for I to be BBC one and two and I
was expecting good results and to be
honest it actually was at the end of the
day it didn't make a huge amount of
difference now maybe I didn't lock into
it like deeply enough I only looked at
basically the global test score over
like a year and a half and there was it
was almost it was basically the exact
same as training and learning the model
in isolation on channel 4 but it would
have been interesting to dive into maybe
like individual program cases and I
suppose to some extent if it was the
World Cup or something like that that's
quite difficult to predict anyway so if
I was trying to base my predictions on
child for on how BBC is going to do I'd
have to be predicting that BBC I'd have
to be predicting the BBC ratings quite
well and also depending I don't think I
had a World Cup in my training set so we
even if I'd come up to a World Cup the
model may well have struggled to like
capture that the work of the huge
sporting event to some extent but yeah
it's a good point and it's definitely it
probably seems intuitive that work I'm
to be honest I probably important often
work into trying to make a work but I
have I've locked into a bit
have you looked at other models like
time series forecasting models that
capture trend and seasonality and things
like that so this was the main one I
focused on the main reason for that was
probably well I suppose a this the model
is actually really good at capturing the
seasonality like it's able to predict
like the overall TV viewership which is
the main source of seasonality and like
time trends it's able to catch those
really really well so what we've
actually done is I mean I didn't want to
go into like too many of the really
small nitty gritty details what we've
actually done is like trigonometry
trigonometry regression so 12 sine and
cosine terms on the day of the year so
we've included those as features and
then learned the parameters to accompany
them which kind of which it just worked
really well are predicting like daily
and yearly trends so so for the week
we've obviously got Dave week dummy
variables and then we've also got hourly
kind of dummy variables but then for the
yearly seasonality it's those that like
accommodation of sine and cosine terms
so we just use that and it actually just
worked really well so I'd actually
didn't try any of the more like standard
methods to be honest
you mentioned random mixed effects
models could you say about the levites
or was it just very basic in terms of
where you live it's just the program you
were looking at and are you somewhere
like what level I had random effects yes
exactly so yeah so here I kind of just
described just having a program random
effect but actually I found what the
best was to kind of have a different
random effect for broadcasts of programs
at different times if that makes sense
so I'd have had a random effect for like
home land at 9:00 but if home land also
aired at noon I'd have a different
random effect for broadcasts so I
actually divided the day into quarters
so any broadcasts between 6:00 and
midnight got clumped into one group of
random effect but if the same show was
broadcast earlier than 6:00 that would
count as a different random effect but I
was not
the biggest most granular I went with
basically in terms of random effect this
is obviously great for modeling
something where as things get more stale
you want to forget them or how do you
deal with things like seasonality where
you'd want to remember what happened
last summer to translate Bayesian
remembering so yeah so I think an
important thing in this model is that
the forgetting was constrained to just
for the program specific random effects
so and also if that program was last on
in the summer it will be remembered but
that's kind of I don't know if that's
really a good answer your question but I
guess the main seasonality hazard is
captured by the fixed effects which
weren't forgotten at all so there was
they were treated as like completely
stationary and they were just learned a
training time and then yeah I was treat
as if they were coming from a fixed
distribution so it was only the past
program ratings that were considered to
be time varying well definitely if there
was like a case where I show exhibited
being really popular in summer but not
in winter the model wouldn't capture
that so that would be another I suppose
that would be another level of
granularity you could add random effects
for a lifetime of year and time of day
which are kind of like interactions to
some extent but we just stopped with
programs within a certain part of the
day yeah
it's not sudden
[Applause]